locked inside a royal crypt
is the founder of boletaria the last
hero
old king doran but for him to be a hero
there must have been a crisis all those
years ago and the most likely scenario
is that wyverns were terrorizing the
land doran's bronze armor
is highly resistant to fire damage as is
the brushwood set
and old armor owned by the bolitarian
royal family since long ago
the brushwood set is only painted the
colour of brushwood
suggesting that the intent might have
been to disguise the wearer as kindling
when in reality they were the opposite
with the dragons baited they could then
be dispatched
after all in the words of doran full
hardiness
aptly wielded is said to be the mark of
the king
and doran had all the marks of a king
indeed
his weapon the northern regalia requires
strength
dexterity comprehension and conviction
to wield and just as well for this sword
was left in the world
to represent a choice it's a weapon made
up of two blades
soulbrandt a weapon for those who seek
soul power at the expense
of others and demon brand a demon
rending blade that represents the
clarity of man instead
doran speaks on the power of souls and
he likely understood
the temptations that come with them so
in the years to come
soul arts and the choices they presented
would remain hidden
it was safer for mankind to be ignorant
and so after the need for his superhuman
strength had faded
he entombed himself with the two swords
the key would remain with the boletarian
royal family
but doran himself a veritable demigod
would pass into legend
but in the dark state of our land
sometimes legends are all we have
no thanks to boletaria the world saw the
rise of monumental civilization
a magic based society that controlled
the world
owing to their mastery of the soul arts
in their insatiable pursuit of power
they discovered the old one and they
worshipped it
as this unfathomable deposit of soul
energy
alas this lust for power was exactly the
warning that was posed by demon brandt
and soulbrand
and the monumentals awoke the old one
marking the beginning
of the first scourge demons ravaged the
world amassing countless souls
and covering the world in this deep
impenetrable fog
by the time the monumentals had fought
off the demons and led the old one back
to slumber
the world as they knew it was lost but
boletaria
one of six lands had survived in order
to mend the fabric of what land
still remained we entrusted
six leaders with six precious arch
stones
one to the king of a small yet
industrious land
in the original japanese text here
rather than the king being
industrious the king is called ambitious
this is an important distinction
for an ambitious king would have envied
the control the monumentals once held
over the world
and aspired a chance to take it for
himself
for the time of the monumentals had
passed and the soul arts had just been
banned so that their mistakes could not
be repeated
but boletaria didn't need soul power
they never had
not since the days of old king doran who
had set in stone this
legacy that represented caution against
the soul arts
unlike the rest of the world boletaria
had survived on their own strength
fostering this culture of honor and
discipline and
a strength in steel and stone now the
titans surrounding them
were wounded fledglings flailing
helplessly without their magic
who can blame the fox to pounce so over
the span
of twelve generations the bloodline of
king alant
worked to expand this small nation we
see evidence of bolitarian conquest in
most areas of the game as well
in stonefang miners fueled the
boletarian war machine
extracting and forging ore under the
watchful eye of the fat officials
in latria the king's own son has
departed with some of their rarest
treasures
and a legendary archer from the shrine
of storms now commands her phalanx for
boletaria
generations of war gave rise to many
famous heroes such as this
there was alfred the tower knight a
mobile fortress
matas the penetrator a walking cavalry
and recently his majesty's twin fangs
bjor
master of the great sword and valofax
who held both wit
and the blade these were heroes to
inspire the common troops
who head off to war clad in iron and
clutching a flower called a blue lotus
it's a flower that treats bleeding
a token from those with loved ones who
pray
that they do not bleed out in battle but
not all soldiers in boletaria drop the
blue lotus
these dreglings are actually called
slave soldiers
in the original japanese they are the
lowest of the low victims of conquest
enslaved and then mercilessly sent back
into war
by their new masters in fact the one
dregling who speaks up
on the mata one who managed to maintain
his sanity
amongst the soul starved comments slyly
that the demons themselves
may make better masters than the
boletarians did
but hell at least the demons don't send
us to our deaths in battle
but what choice did they have stationed
on the castle outskirts
visible to all are the execution grounds
where the king's own executioner miralda
is tasked with eliminating his enemies
defy his majesty's will
and miralda will make an example of you
with many slave soldiers already
condemned to become
raging spirits even in death
you wretched traitor to the king
so they stitch themselves up and they
strew together what defenses they
can scavenge from the battlefield they
are all but living corpses
paving the way for the great heroes of
boletaria
history is written by the victors after
all
proletariat the king his knights and his
subjects were modest and plain
but also steadfast and compassionate
i've spent much time in my studies in
the cultured countries of the south
yet no country holds my heart as does
boletaria
by this point magic and the soul arts
were but a distant memory
yes boletaria had thrived without their
use but their other sins had become
too numerous to count slave soldiers
conquest
deception this is the legacy that king
allan xii
inherited on the day of his coronation
to his credit
it is said that he cared for his
subjects and fought valiantly on their
behalf but
remember boletaria is the conqueror not
the conquered and alant
would have been facing pressure to
expand the kingdom as generations of
fathers had done before him
and so for the first time in 12
generations
he decided to take up a sword from the
old king's mausoleum
but which would he choose demon brand or
soul brand
his hand passed over demon brand to pull
solebrand from its grave
and he kept it ever by his side after
all there were no demons where he was
slaying
only men his path from here was to
become increasingly lonely
by the time he reached old age we can
only count two
left in his life his son prince ariona
alant
and rydel lord of the frontier despite
being middle-aged
lord radiel is referred to as little
alant
implying that he's the elderly king's
younger brother or
a similarly close relative he certainly
takes on less responsibility than king
alant
donning dirty leather instead of royal
garb and
enjoying more of a reputation as an
adventurer than as a lord
for there is a legend associated with
redeal it's said that the weapon he
wields the phosphorescent pole
was stolen from a witch in the sky these
words bring the maiden in black to mind
she's a witch who favors a long staff
living in a sky temple that hovers above
a hinterland of icy mountains
the exact same sort of mountains that
ridiell was stationed to look over
is too perfect all evidence points
towards the king
venturing to this land before ridiel and
alant
to stage a raid a heist upon the temple
to take from them as they had taken from
so many others
but what the elder allant would have
found in this temple
the nexus changed everything the king
learned about the soul
and could see the potential that it
carried all around him with this
knowledge
he returned home to share these soul
arts
with his subjects and sorcery spread
like wildfire once again
spells and magic rings exploded in
popularity and
began leaking across the continent
having finally embraced the power of the
soul
boletaria flourished like never before
so much so
that we even find an example of poor
commoners affording
luxuries like jade if alant cared about
the impiety inherent in
propagating these soul arts their
utility would have far
outweighed any concerns he had by every
other metric
boletaria was undeniably better off
within this new era of discovery
prince ariona embarked upon his own
investigation
to tour the advanced countries to the
kingdom's south
to learn unimpeded the royal dressed as
your average knight in the region
by the name strava but to be safe his
father also sent one of his twin
fangs as an escort leaving bjor to earn
a reputation abroad
as the best-known user of his weapon and
his armor with the warrior's
companionship abroad the prince acquired
all manner of strange inventions
both mundane and magical alike
everything appeared to be going so well
but was it really kingilant xii
stood in his tower finally looking back
at his own shadow
and it was ugly an empire built on the
ambition of his bloodline
rooted in generations of cruelty and
bloodshed he was now also totally alone
his son was abroad his wife is never
mentioned
and little ridiel is last seen in la
tree
locked up in a cell alan's
dissatisfaction with humanity
is also reflected in his royal
appointments around this time
the kingdom's day-to-day operations
would have been run by the fat officials
openly shady sycophants who were only
too happy to
indulge their king's apathy for his
kingdom abusing their subjects at home
and abroad on the day of his coronation
alant had chosen
soulbrand the bane of men and with none
outside his kingdom
left to conquer maybe he turned his
attention inwards to his own kingdom
alan had stolen the soul arts from the
nexus so it follows that the monumentals
there
would have warned him of the
consequences beneath the nexus was an
ancient evil
a poison that god had placed upon the
world to counter man's own evil
should they use the soul arts for their
own power surely
you have seen for yourself the pain
and suffering that fills this world
but god is
all alone the king departed for the
nexus and unsealed the old one
back in the time that i lived below
boletaria castle
king land left on some strange business
then returned with horrible demons in
tow
soon the lamb was ravaged by
soul-starved mad men
he had fought like a demon for the sake
of his legacy
and now it was time he actually became
one the old one will
feed upon our souls and put an end to
this
tragedy however fates toyed with him
for alant is not the demon a top
boletaria
instead he became a wretched abomination
deep below
barely able to lift himself off the
ground this demon form more accurately
reflects his suffering
when you think about it but even if it
wasn't perfect he had still gained
the powers of an archdemon and that was
enough
within the fog reality was whatever
alant made it
and so we see the demons of his
imagination
artifacts like the purple flame shield
had pointed back to wyvens for
generations
so alan's let them return as demons
his new demon knights towered higher
than ever
based off the real knights whose deaths
were all but inevitable
and alan's most precious demon was a
doppelganger who presided over it all
and who appeared to lead the demons so
betrayed by their liege
each heroic knight was killed except for
one
valofax who escaped to the fog's edge
despite the mortal injuries that he
suffered the twin fang
still managed to tear open a fissure in
the fog
and warned the outside world of what had
transpired inside
before he died refusing to believe the
revelations
bjor entered valafax's tear only to be
defeated by the castle's wivens
and its black phantoms who were the
spirits of his friends
enslaved by the very traitor who
corrupted them with bjor thrown in jail
under the fat official's care
and left to rot prince ariona never
heard back from him
and ultimately decided to enter the fog
alone years later where his inexperience
shines through
and while bjor eventually comes to terms
with the truth about the king he admired
ariona can't accept what his father has
become and he eventually takes his own
life
in the face of that reality i began this
quest to ask my father his reasons
to drag him back to the path of
righteousness
but it seems it was all in vain
but in the words of a strava in
boletaria's darkest hour legends are all
it can depend upon
and in the deep fog the line between
legend and reality
is blurred the hero's spirit can now be
roused from its slumber
his form can be made flesh along with
his fabled weapon
and armor and he can be bound as the
eternal guardian
to the last sword in his crypt demon
brat
the sword allant should have chosen from
the very beginning
only those equal to the crown may take
it souls that rival
a demigod are you worthy prepare
thyself brave knight
[Music]
if you liked this video then please
check out its sponsor nordvpn
so right now they're offering a huge
discount on two-year plans and
if you go to nordvpn.com and use code
vaatividia then you'll get one
additional month for free
with nordvpn it just takes one click and
then your connection is
acting as if it's originating from
another ip in
another country one of the features i
always make sure i always turn on
is the split tunneling setting which
allows the vpn to
ignore certain things like the
multiplayer games i play but
always guarantee that i'm anonymous
through certain browsers like
chrome or firefox for some people the
perks of anonymity might simply be that
you see less targeted ads on the
internet
it can be creepy sometimes when targeted
ads are too good
but for others things can be more
serious some governments prevent you
from
accessing certain kinds of news and you
can't trust
a lot of them not to track what you're
searching no matter how you spin it vpns
are just a powerful tool to have at your
disposal and
not vpn is cheap right now so maybe take
advantage of that go to nordvpn.com and
use code
vaatividia for that free extra month and
the huge discount
thank you for watching